thank you David and yeah so the plan is
that shahar and I will share this part
of the boot camp and there'll be six
lectures in all spread over these days
and so I start today in the morning with
a basic introduction to communication
complexity and Sahar comes this
afternoon with an introduction to the
combinatorial applications of
information theory tomorrow morning I
will use some of the definitions that
shahar sets up so it's not terribly
important but there will be some sort of
a connection and we coordinate between
us so today's lecture I understand that
many of you are actually experts on
communication complexity but this
lecture today is not for experts at all
so I will just start as the assumption
that you probably not seen communication
complexity and
so this is the familiar setup so you
have two parties one is called Alice the
other is called Bob and Alice has an
element as a input X from some alphabet
capital X and Bob has an input Y from
some alphabet Capital y and they have a
fixed function in mind which they wish
to compute this is some sort of
broken-down model of distributed
computing and they wish to compute this
f on their input X Y by exchanging
messages
so and our goal is somehow to minimize
or their goal is to minimize the total
amount of communication there is the
total length of messages that go between
Ellison
so they do this using they communicate
using a protocol and for our purposes
today what we mean by product by a
protocol is a tree so
idea is that once they have their inputs
X & Y they start communicating they
communicate using bits and for speaks
first and who speaks next is somehow
encoded industry as follows so just
because there is an a on top it means
Alice starts first and based on her
input X she either sends a 0 or a 1 so
some inputs she is going to send a 0 for
other inputs she is going to send one
and then if she sends 0 then Bob decides
what to do and this way they continue
until the leech reach a leaf and at the
leaf the value of the function is stored
so at the moment everything is
deterministic and the protocol is
represented as this is this alright so
far
so
so once you fix the input x and y the
leaf that you reach is completely
determined and that leaf I call leaf X
comma Y and there is this part that the
computation took and that path will be
called the transcript on X&Y fixed and
fast can be something I mean no sorry do
you know no this is a tree so I'm sorry
I didn't yeah I should yeah so this is a
tree so the moment the leaf so it is
fair to say that the leaf also is a
transcript but we just pretend that the
transcript is the whole thing so Jacob
question fact yoga a on that branch
means that your basis of one they'll
continue selling some place sorry yeah
that's right so we don't insist that the
players strictly alternate okay so whose
turn it is next is determined by the
label on the node in the current
computation so at the moment if a
happens to send a one Bob should
understand that he shouldn't speak yet
it's Alice's turn to send the next bit
and eventually when they reach hopefully
a note here which is labeled B is then
that Bob will send a bit
so what bob is going to play next what
did you mean all right that's at least
have the whole knowledge of this graph
yes she has the whole knowledge of this
graph they both in fact when they had
this function f they first sat down and
built this gruff and then they went away
Alice was given her ex bob was given his
Y and then they started claim ok but for
every input x and y the leaf that is
reached should in fact contain the
correct answer to this function only
then will we call this a valid protocol
for this problem and now the total
length of messages is kind of easily
seen in this that is the length the
depth of this tree the length of the
longest path from the root to leaf
industry so the old when they sat down
to build this tree was to build the tree
of minimum height which achieves this
so the deterministic complexity of the
function f is trim over all protocols
so who tells us what to say at the next
round it's got to be something that oh
so actually at each node is there's also
a particular function f and g sorry i
shouldn't use the same letter H so this
is an H which is specific to this node
so each node has a particular function
that labels it Alice's functions are
just functions of x 201 Bob's functions
are just from why 201 isn't Alice's
function function of X and whatever is
seen from borrow that one so yeah so the
fact that it is at the node already
takes so yeah so the okay so the
official sort of definition of
communication complexity when everything
is written without pictures and trees
you say that what you say next is a
function of what you saw so far and your
input but we since we are ya doing it in
a picture I think that is taken care of
somehow what you see in the past defines
a particular node that's right so so
yeah it's taken care of so I think so I
mean it it's this is a reasonably good
way to start in the beginning and many
recent results on communication
complexity then they talk about you know
compression and the information costs
actually use the protocol tree in this
form so yeah it's no big loss not to
have done the original definition all
right
so the first so I want to give some
examples of functions that can be
analyzed and the first function i want
to think about is be
quality function so what are x and y in
this case catholics is the set of all n
bit strings and the capital y is the set
of all n bit strings and the output that
they wished compute is just a single bit
okay and as you might have guessed they
need to determine if if X is equal to Y
or not
the deterministic complexity of the
Equality function is at most n for any
function on where one of the parties has
n bits the deterministic complexity can
cannot be more than n because it's
always possible for that party to just
send the entire input over to the other
place the other thing the way I have set
it up here in the end you might think
that only one party gets to know the
answer and that's the way it will be ok
as long as one party knows the answer we
say that the problem has been solved
alright so that's art and you just sort
of show this that
there cannot be a better protocol then
this trivial protocol deterministically
where one party sends the entire input
so this probably fairly obvious there
are many ways to see this but I'll my
goal is to somehow introduce various
concepts of communication complexity
through this example so I'll just tell
you something called so now let's look
at a particular leaf here and let's ask
what inputs arrive at this leaf
so to arrive at this leaf Addison Bob
must both cooperate yeah there is a
unique part to this leaf and if either
of them sends you off the path that you
will not get to this leaf so
those inputs X and Y which take you to
this leaf l will be called a rectangle
why they should be called a rectangle we
will see very soon but let us look at
all those inputs that take you to this
particular leaf that I call the
rectangle that is associated with this
turns out that this particular set is
actually cross product of two sets one
which somehow looks at it from the point
of view of Alice and the other looks at
it from the point of view of ball ok so
what I'm trying to say is that L is of
the form s cross T where
said it somehow in English so what do we
mean by this so suppose you have a
particular ad and we want to know
whether the computation will reach here
what does Alice suppose we asked Alice
do you think the computation will reach
here Alice just checks all the nodes
that have a as a label on this path and
sees whether her input X is compatible
with this path that is is it true that
at any of these a nodes Alice would have
had an input which would have taken it
or Alice's input would have taken it off
this bar so that is the set s first
possible that that depends on what's in
the path that Bob made a decision on so
once you have reached a particular node
Bob decisions are already known because
so it just depends only on Alice's input
you've come to this node a and at with
label a and we ask will this function H
which labels this a I'll put a zero no I
agree that's true once you get this
there may be other paths which bar made
different decisions that the house has
exactly the same X so if Alice has an X
which bills so all nodes labeled a
Alice's X's Alice's X will take you in
the right direction ok and suppose it's
also the case that Bob's input bill is
also compatible with this transcript
then this pair x and y is compatible
with this part so that's what I'm saying
there are two decisions one of them to
be made by Alice and the other to be
made by Bob Alice's decisions are
entirely determined by her input and
Bob's decisions are entirely determined
by his input and and that is the reason
so now let's see function f itself it's
a function of two inputs so we might
write it as a table here so these are so
Alice's input and these are bobs inputs
and typical input of alice is x a
typical input of Bobby's and we write f
of X now each leaf l we associate a
rectangle so that is
some set of inputs of Alice some set of
inputs of Bob and
for all these inputs the protocol takes
you to the same leaf that means the
answer is the same the entire rectangle
we reach the same leaf and it is the
same common answer z so that means each
such rectangle that corresponds to a
leaf is monochromatic
if you had a protocol and you looked at
its rectangle and you place that
rectangle onto this matrix m of f so
what is M of f you you label the rows by
X the columns by Y and write f of X Y
here and look at those locations of this
table which correspond to this rectangle
and what you will find is that if this
is a valid protocol than all entries in
this rectangle will have to be using
now if this matrix doesn't admit large
monochromatic rectangles so this matrix
is such that it doesn't admit large
monochromatic rectangles then what we
conclude is that the number of leaves in
your protocol tree must be last and if
your leap number of leaves is large then
that will also have to be large it's
just a binary tree what did we do we
talked about rectangles we noticed that
rectangles have to be monochromatic and
somehow we said if we can force a large
number of rectangles to decompose this
matrix then we will have somehow shown a
lower bound on the deterministic
complexity of the function so let's just
implement this plan for the quality
function and maybe in a complicated way
prove this what does the the
communication matrix for the Equality
function then let's order the X's here
and the Y's here and these are all
elements of 0 1 to the N and let's use
the same pod ring yeah so then the
Equality
you have once only on the diagonals and
zeros elsewhere and you can notice that
each of these ones has to be part of
some rectangle every input is part of
some rectangle 4 of the protocol why
because look at this input X and Y which
takes you so and then feed this x and y
to the protocol and see where it gets
and that n will include this x and y so
every input is part of some rectangle so
each of these is also part of some
rectangle and so the number of such
the important thing is to of these ones
cannot be part of the same rectangle
because a rectangle is supposed to be
monochromatic so if it includes two ones
then it will also include then zero here
which it is not allowed to so each of
these ones has to be part of a different
rectangles so the number of rectangles
has to be at least 2 to the N and
lower bound of n yeah the number of
leaves becomes 2 to the end so that has
to be at least
I mean to you say that the rectangle
that contains one it has to be one by
one one by one trick tang and what about
the rectangles that contain 20 can they
be bigger they can be bigger yes you
don't care about OIC so they're 2 to the
N ones already serves are already that
gives me the end is to end by two sorry
yeah I should say sighs I'm let's go to
the n cross 2 to the N ladies
because I do have a question so there
aren't these two to the n rectangles but
there are some zero rectangles as
wellit's so you get more than two to the
N leave so how do you account for that
there might be a plus or minus one in
the my formulation because the answer
needs to get to both yeah I should have
paid attention I do so at the moment it
looks like my lower bound is more than
my upper bound yeah fix that he'll come
back
oh so now this Alison Bob yeah so they
have the same inputs we're still talking
about the Equality problem and allowed
to now toss coins and what do we mean by
that the two models that will be
discussing about randomized
communication complexity and one of them
is private coins
so
I think the answer is that the way we
set this up the referee needs to know
the answer okay so by that looking at
the transcript we should be able to tell
the answer and if you set the
definitions right according to that
you'll probably get n plus one for more
so there are two models of randomized
communication complexity and one is
private coins and the other is public oh
and I will just tell you what it is so
you have Allison bar so i'm talking
about the private coins model so they in
addition to that input they have a
source of randomness sorry and yes
tosses some points and
they call that RFA and similarly Bob
tosses some coins and we call the type
of P Alice's entire actions will now be
determined not only by X but also by her
coin tosses and similarly Bob's actions
will be determined by Y as well as RFP
so in terms of protocol tree so in the
private coins model it's easy to sort of
model the effect of this using a
protocol tree so what was our old
protocol tree when it was Alice's turn
based on our input she just decides to
go left or right and similarly when it
was Bob Stern he went left or right
based on the input why now when we are
at such a node Alice can go left or
right with certain probabilities it
doesn't have to be just zero or what
okay so she could say my input is such
that i would like to go left with
probability one foots and right with
probability three falls so we just
imagine that it's the same thing it's
the same protocol tree and everything
and but at each node what we have is
a probability p + 1 minus p and this p +
1 minus p can depend the value p can
depend on the input X what probability
she need she wants to go left or right
depends on her input X and again the
fact that it can also depend on what Bob
has said so far is all captured but the
fact that you have reached this node so
now for each input X as soon as the
input is available to Alice Alice will
be able to set up p + 1 minus p and on
all the nodes with label a and bob
similarly sets up his q1 minus Q values
for all the nodes that are labeled B ok
then the computation starts and now it's
a walk down this tree which is governed
by these probabilities and then you
reach a particular leaf and you announce
the answer
public coins modern
so we don't
we don't have this rejection common
random string is available here both
Alice and Bob can consult it at any time
and so then you come to a particular
node you decide to go left or right
based on your input and also the common
random string so in other words if we
fix one value of the common random
string then this becomes a deterministic
protocol it need not be correct in the
sense that we are loved and I will tell
you what the role of epsilon is in the
correctness or the definition of
correctness you get a tree for each
random choice are so actually you can
think of a public coins protocol as a
probability distribution over
deterministic protocols so just see an
example for equality and then hopefully
things will become clear
Alice has n bits bob has n bits and they
need to determine if the inputs are
identical
answer that okay so we'll talk about
private coins protocols later but let's
talk about public coins first turns out
that there's a dramatic difference in
the amount of communication needed to
solve this problem if you allow a little
bit of error okay so
what do I mean by this I am NOT going to
write down the entire definition but let
me just say it we want to minimize the
worst-case communication the worst-case
communication of a randomized protocol
that uses public coins computes the
function f with probability 1 minus
epsilon that means for every input the
probability of error should be at most
epsilon so once you fix a particular
input the protocol runs it might give
the correct answer or not but the
probability of error should be at most
Epsilon this should be true for every
epsilon and protocol which achieves this
among all such protocols we take the one
which has the minimum worst-case
communication and that is defined
defined to be the randomized public coin
epsilon error complexity of F okay when
we are talking about private coins we
just replace this by private and then we
have just notation okay so
here Alice has X bob has why and there
is a random string re so we are free to
visualize what random string we want
here and then build the protocol
according to that so a natural random
string that we can put here is a
in other words this random string is a
random hash function from n bits to one
bit so the way it is stated it is
actually a table of length 2 to the N
each of the two to the N possible inputs
we have either a 0 or a 1 so they're
using huge amounts of randomness but at
the moment that's allowed in the model
what we are interested in is how much
communication do in
what does Alice send bomb and its views
the common randomness as a hash function
she applies that hash function to her
input X sends it to Bob yeah so Alice
sends 8x and Bob checks if H of X what
does what happens if X is equal to Y
then probability of error two inputs are
the same there's the hash function is
going to result in the same value
there'll be no error but if X is not
equal to Y then
this table of H Allison Bob will be
consulting different locations and the
probability that these two values turn
out to be the same is that most half
we have set it up it's probably huh
it's possible that even though the two
inputs are different Alice and Bob come
to the conclusion that or at least claim
that they are the same but this happens
with probability at most half now if you
wanted this probability to be made
smaller you could just replace this 2012
the K yeah and then this will go so this
epsilon can be made smaller by just
changing so you can see with constant
amount of communication with constant
amount of communication in the public
coins model we can bring down the error
to any small constant but where is it
constant is late k oh sorry so if no
depends on the error right so if you
want any constant error epsilon based on
that error maybe log 1 over epsilon is
the communication
on the hash functions oh so meaning each
of these hash values here are they
independently chosen yep so my so yeah
when I said that pick a random hash
function I meant among all hash
functions take the collection of all
hash functions and pick one at random so
if you do that then each of these bits
will be uniformly 0 or 1 and also
independent of each other so at this
point one could ask I mean this looks
really horrible that is we seem to be
cheating in the sense that we are using
a large amount of randomness of course
that is not being generated looking at
the input but could we make this smaller
yeah so
if you just think about it we just
needed some sort of pairwise
independence instead of total
independence so we could using this
model of hash functions we could just
visualize this are to be an element of 0
1 to the N and what Alice sends is the
dot product of X and Z and Bob checks 01
of a I'm sorry this is hard yeah what
did I do
so this is still in 2 to the n bits of
randomness now we are using n bits of
randomness and if we really think about
it so what we are doing is somehow
computing the Haddam our code of x and y
so these are all possible and bit
strings
and x is an n-bit string we take its dot
product mod 2 and we choose one of these
so clear what I mean by this matrix this
is all possible strings of 10 bits we
choose one of these rows take its dot
product with X and send it to one and
Bob takes the same row computes the dot
product with Y and checks whether they
are equal or not and what we know is
that if X is different from Y then there
will be the the output yeah x multiplied
by this matrix will differ from Y
multiplied by this matrix on at least
half the places so again we will get
that the probability of error is at most
half when inputs are different but when
the inputs X and Y are the same then the
output is definitely
so once we start viewing this as some
code you immediately realize that it was
not important for us to use the harder
Michael we could use any we could use
any error correcting code so we could
first and this here is what Alice does
she treats her and bit input X as the
message and encodes it using some error
correcting code let's say with
polynomial length and Bob that's the
same thing then Alice can take a
particular I in the particular bit of
this error correcting code of this code
word and send it to Bob and Bob can
check because it that bit agrees with
his bit or not and with constant if the
x and y are the same then with
probability 1 the value will be the same
but if x and y are different with
constant probability they will detect
that x is not equal to y now if that
constant is not good enough we can
repeat and drive the probability down
we care about minimum distance because
we want in the different inputs X and Y
their code words should differ on a good
fraction of please let me write down the
protocol care about the distance because
takes a particular code which takes n
bits to let us say polynomially many in
n bits then what does Alice do Alice in
this range and sense
and Bob checks if C of X I is famous and
then x and y are different we want this
test to fail with a decent probability
and for that we want C of X he just
looks a self oh please the slices like
the long code yeah we are using very
long coat this the intermediate thing I
talked about was the harder man code and
now we say that it doesn't matter what
code we use as as long as it has some
distance yeah we will be able to detect
the difference between x and y with
constant probability
so what's the communication complexity
in on this ya seem to have lost track of
that yeah so how many bits does Ellis
sent he needs to send the eye and the
actual bit because that is what Bob will
compare so and that is the reason we
were careful about this being polynomial
alone yeah so in a private sorry what
was I saying so I am still talking about
public coins so in public coins it goes
does not matter in private coins now Bob
can send this sorry Alice can pick this
I at random in the range 1 to Polly in n
that is log in bits and then send this
extra one bit and thats all Bob needs to
complete the task ok so the total
communication
if we allow public points then we could
drive the arrow down to some small
constant with constant amount of
communication but if we didn't have
public coins shared randomness and we
insisted that all the randomness be
local to the two parties we could still
get efficient protocols but it looks
like we are doing it with log in bits of
communication not constant okay now
turns out that this is not something
isolated to the Equality function so
there is a theorem which says that you
can always come transform a public coins
protocol to a private coins protocol
with an overhead of log in so let me
just write that down
what is this n so if the inputs are n
bits long yeah then you have an
efficient public coins protocol then
with an overhead of order log n we also
have an efficient private coins protocol
this is true for all functions we saw a
particular instance of this for the
quality function because the public
coins complexity was only constant
the other question we need to ask is is
it true that we need login if you allow
yourself only private coins and the
answer is yes and we'll talk about it
next time so lower bounds for randomized
communication complexity will be the
topic of the next lecture tomorrow and
we will see this and many other such
examples epsilon let's think of it as
something like one fourths yeah private
of the Equality function I think
everything I've said today has been
basic and may be easily anticipated it I
just want to show one so surprising
protocol and
so what's the problem Alice as X
bob has why they both are n bit strings
Alice's input and Bob's input on both n
bit strings and let's say we have even
been told that X is not equal to Y so
they've been given inputs which differ
and what they have to find out
here's X Y and they differ and this is
the position that perhaps one of them
has a zero in the other has a one to the
left of this they're all equal okay and
they need to communicate in order to
find out the first position where they
different and they are allowed to use
randomness they are allowed to use
public trans eminence and they need to
find out this location we can use
typical computer science tricks okay so
we sort of look at left half in the
right half ok we asked oh who is this
position in the left half or is it in
the right half now how do we find out
whether it's in the left half a right
half we just check whether this equal or
naughty okay so how do we do that well
we have seen three different ways of
doing it but anyway we can do a
randomized protocol to determine if
there is a difference in the left half
or not if there is no difference in the
left half they work on the right half in
the country so in log n steps yeah and
at each step
they find out whether to go left or
right and after login steps they come
down to the location the leftmost
location now how small do we need to
keep the error there are login equality
protocols that are being run okay and if
we do things knively each of them can
have a certain probability of error and
these probabilities add up okay so just
to keep the probabilities down we would
like to choose sorry it is my K but
there used to be a one would do to the K
here if we allowed K bits of
communication then the error went down
as 1 over 2 to the K so we would like to
keep the K as such that this number
becomes something like 1 over log in so
k as log log in
so there is a
login times log log n bits protocol okay
let you imagine how it works yeah based
on equality repeatedly use equality keep
the arrow down at all stages and log in
rounds each with log log and bits of
communication so
so
so I get bellagrog one and look fun they
did something thing clever and got rid
of this log log in and i just want to
show you how that works and again using
the same equality protocol as the basis
but yeah
so imagine you have three set up on this
there are these n possible answers that
you could give and you just arrange them
as a binary tree and the the protocol
that I explained here it seems to be
walking down this tree to the right
place where x and y differ the leftmost
place where they differ and at each step
it's friends log log and bits
the protocols they propose has the
following property each round we will
only be doing constant amounts of
communication but we will be going the
wrong way once in a while okay so if I
we decide to use only K bits of
communication than with probability 1
over 2 to the K we might have gone the
wrong way but we will always keep in
mind that we would have gone the wrong
way and we sometimes go back up the tree
so what this protocol will do is sort of
go down maybe come up yeah
and so eventually it will get to the
letter e so you both go down and up so
let me just quickly tell you what we
need to do if you are at this node
industry and you want to decide whether
to go left right or up can you remind us
where these feel better but that what it
means to be at that mode okay so you did
the first round of computations this you
ran an equality protocol here and you
decided that the error is in the left
left half first is left yes yep and then
when you have come to this node that
means you have somehow isolated you
believe that this I lies in in this
interval so it to be at this node means
to believe that your eye is in this
interval so now I'm going to test okay
so yeah so we want to know where in this
interval of this interval consists of
two sub intervals corresponding to the
left tree and the right tree and then
there is stuff to the left here when you
come to this string you just run an
equality protocol on this part once
again just to check maybe you know we
came down here by mistake okay and if it
is here then we that okay if that
equality protocol says look you know it
still looks somewhat equal then you
continue check this left part and if you
discover a difference there then you go
down but once you go down here it
doesn't mean that you believe this again
check okay so at every step you check if
there is some reason that right okay and
you do all this with a large-ish k I am
NOT going to tell you the details so at
any node there is an obvious direction
to go in order to get here that
is this direction and these are all bad
directions if you use a big enough k you
can set it up so that you always move
with probability three-fourths in the
right direction this luxury of this is
not you action in spite of death death
of the that's right yeah so I will need
to tell you how many times you will keep
moving up and down and just yep I'll
tell you that okay but right now the
knife protocol is this when you are at a
particular node decide whether you
should go back up go left or go right
and all this is done by running the
basic equality protocol with suitable
now the question was does it ever get
here yeah and when does it get here okay
and does it get within login steps yeah
so here's what I suggest you there is a
correct leaf right you hold that leaf
and kind of hang the tree from hold this
leaf and hang the tree the branches are
all heavy they kind of go down just Pat
it up yeah right so it becomes a life
right so this special node I the leaf I
is here and then there are there is a
tree which hangs out and so then many
nodes which there might be leaves which
terminated are here but just Pat them up
yeah now if you see look at this process
is it not a random walk on this line
with a drift three-fourths always in the
direction of I and one foots away no
matter where you are the probability of
getting closer to I is always at least
three-fourths
yeah and the total length is login now I
will let you convince yourself that if
you have such a random work the
probability that after login steps you
have still not hit the same of the
constant 10 times log in steps is very
soon
this is the protocol sorry it went over
time thank you very much and see you